that service that commitment honor Pride
that's why I became a police
officer my name is Michael Dominique I
served in the United States Marine Corps
left as a sergeant I served in Iraq and
South America I'm here as a police
officer at Yale University one of the
hardest things coming back from Iraq was
um acclimating back into everyday
Society people don't know exactly what
you've gone through especially if you go
into war they don't know uh that uh comr
that you've had when you've uh served
alongside other veterans the majority of
the service members that I looked up to
growing up they're no longer here before
a lot of them passed I was able to uh
show that sign of respect by becoming a
Marine uh joining the service so that's
what a veteran Day means to
me